en este vídeo quiero dar una
introducción al tema de las progresiones
geométricas voy a escribir por aquí
progresiones geométricas y bueno tengo
un montón de vídeos más avanzados de
este tema pero pensé que sería una buena
idea tener un vídeo básico para que
entendamos muy bien esta noción de
progresiones geométricas y bueno una muy
buena forma de empezar para explicar
este concepto es explicar qué es una
progresión de números una progresión de
números es tomarnos algunos números
acomodados de izquierda a derecha por
ejemplo 1 2 3 4 5 es una progresión de
números no va a ser una progresión
geométrica como ahorita vamos a ver pero
si es una progresión ahora una
progresión geométrica es un tipo
especial de progresión entonces que debe
de cumplir esta progresión debe de
cumplir lo siguiente que cada término
está multiplicado por un número fijo
vamos a ver un ejemplo para que
entendamos cómo sucede esto supongamos
que hay que el primer número de nuestra
progresión es 2 y supongamos que se lo
multiplicamos por 3
por tres ajá entonces si multiplicamos
por tres nos queda seis multiplicando
seis por tres nos queda 18 multiplicando
18 por 33 por 18 nos quedan 54 y así
podríamos seguir escribiendo nuestra
progresión geométrica entonces cuál fue
el chiste que tenemos un término inicial
a ver vamos a ponerle un poco de
notación este de aquí es el primer
término le voy a poner a uno y cada vez
este primer término lo fuimos
multiplicando por un número que
permaneció fijo a este número fijo vamos
a llamarle la razón común en este caso a
uno es igual a 2 y r&r que es la razón
común es igual a 3 le voy a poner aquí
que es la razón la razón común
ahora bueno supongamos que alguien llega
y nos dice que tenemos una progresión
geométrica que tiene a uno igual a 90
que suterm iniciales 90 y que la razón
común es menos un tercio entonces eso
qué quiere decir vamos a intentar
desarrollar esta progresión
el primero es 90 el segundo es menos un
tercio x 90 que es que es menos 30 y
menos un tercio por 90 es menos 30 luego
hay que volver a multiplicar por menos
un tercio a ver nos queda menos por
menos nos queda más un tercio por 30 nos
queda 10
entonces nos que debería quedar positivo
y nos va a quedar un 10 entonces queda
10 si el siguiente número es 10 por
menos un tercio es menos diez tercios
hay que multiplicar una vez más por
menos un tercio entonces menos por menos
da más es diez tercios y así podríamos
seguir y seguir y seguir con nuestra
progresión salen entonces esto que
platicamos es a lo que la gente se
refieren cuando hablan de una progresión
geométrica quiero hacer una pequeña
distinción aquí porque es todo esto
a confundirme un poco déjame hablar de
otro término que se usa en un contexto
similar esto de aquí que es una
progresión del número son algunos
números acomodados uno por uno
verdad como aquí abajo hay perdón este
último de acá es diez novenos verdad es
menos un tercio por diez tercios menos
por menos es más si nos queda diez
novenos verdad no tercios novenos ahora
estás de aquí son progresiones pero tal
vez también hayas escuchado la palabra
serie o más específicamente tal vez
hayas escuchado la expresión seria
geométrica sí y resulta que son términos
distintos una progresión y una serie son
cosas distintas una serie cuando cuando
en matemáticas se dice serie usualmente
nos referimos a la suma de algunos
términos aquí abajo tenemos una
progresión pero si por otro lado
quisiéramos tener una serie entonces
tendríamos que sumar 90 más menos 30 más
10 más menos 10 tercios más 10 novenos
y entonces una forma de pensarlo es qué
serie se refiere a la suma de algunos
términos de una progresión quería dejar
eso claro porque eso solía confundirme
cuando yo estudié estas cosas primero
pero bueno hecha esta aclaración
regresemos al tema en cuestión que son
las progresiones geométricas y lo que
ahorita vamos a hacer es un problema
ejemplo entonces vamos a ver qué nos
dice el problema el problema nos dice
que anna va a saltar del bonche sale
entonces copiamos el problema a nada va
a saltar del bong y lo ponemos por aquí
y nos dan cierta información que tiene
que ver con cómo se va estirando la
cuerda cada vez que el bong el rebote
ahí va al principio al principio en el
primer brinco la cuerda lo voy a poner
aún no va a ser nuestro termini cial la
cuerda se estira 120 120 pies sale ahora
déjenme escribir una tabla porque nos
van a dar más información
voy a poner una columna de brincos y voy
a poner una segunda columna de cuanto se
estira de cuánto se estira la cuerda del
bungee entonces en el en el brinco
inicial en el brinco número uno la
cuerda se estira
20 pies salen y lo que nos dice el
problema es que cada vez que rebotan a
la cuerda se estira el 60% de la
anterior es decir digan voy a escribirlo
por aquí a la derecha es la razón común
que nos dan es 60% pero eso escrito en
número es 0.6 sale y entonces cada vez
es la razón por la cual se multiplica el
estiramiento en el segundo brinco va a
ser 0.6 x 120 esta multiplicación la
podemos hacer nos da 72 en el tercer
brinco se va a volver a multiplicar por
0.6 sea 0.6 lo de arriba que es 0.6 por
0.6 por 120 y eso de ahí bueno vamos al
cuarto brinco nos queda a ver veamos qué
pasa
hay que multiplicar el tercero otra vez
por 0.6
entonces es 0.6 x 0.6 multiplicado por
otro 0.6 y x 120 que es el tema inicial
es el 60% del tercer brinco
sale entonces si quisiéramos hacer una
fórmula general para este problema vamos
a escribirla por acá si quisiéramos
hacer una fórmula general vamos a poner
vamos a llamar el estiramiento en el
enésimo brinco que tendríamos que hacer
bueno debe de tener un debe tener un 120
va a poner voy a poner por aquí el 120 y
eso hay que multiplicarlo hay que
multiplicarlo por 0.6 lo voy a poner
aquí a la izquierda y 0.6 y hay que
elevarlo a qué potencia hay que elevarlo
a la potencia inm uno como él dice para
escribir eso déjame reescribir un poco
la fórmula para que quede un poco más y
mejor escrita
esto es 0.6 no nos de hecho dejar de
escribir el 120 primero esto es igual a
120 x 0.6 y eso elevado a la n-1 hay
toda la explicación saber nos vamos para
acá para la izquierda para la tabla en
el primer brinco se estira 120 si
ponemos en iguala 1 en el exponente aquí
nos queda uno menos uno que es cero nos
queda 0.6 a la cero que es un 1 y ese 1
también lo tenemos en la tabla aquí está
120 en el segundo brinco queda 2 - 1 en
el exponente 2 - 11 nos queda 0.6 y ahí
está el 0.6 entonces me di cuenta que
era n menos 1 porque en el brinco 2 era
un 10.6 cuando era 3 había 20 puntos 6
cuando era 4 había 30.6 era 0.6 al cubo
entonces cualquier cosa que sea en la
potencia debe ser n
1 entonces nos queda esta fórmula de
aquí que nos dice el problema el
problema nos pregunta acerca del
estiramiento en el rebote número 12 pero
fíjate que es el rebote entonces tenemos
que hacer algún cambio a ver a ver a ver
voy a sacar la calculadora pero antes de
eso
antes de eso vamos a replantear un
poquito el problema no hemos hecho nada
así demasiado mal pero como se está
hablando del doceavo rebote y aquí lo
que habíamos hecho es una tabla con
brincos vamos a hacer un cambio en
nuestro planteamiento del problema no
íbamos mal pero el cambio es para que se
parezca un poco más a lo que nos piden
entonces el brinco número uno podemos
pensarlo como
de cero aquí en donde dice brincos le
voy a cambiar para que ahora diga rebote
y así el primer renglón de la fila
estiramiento ahora corresponde al rebote
cero y luego tenemos el primero el
segundo y el tercer rebote vean cómo se
desplaza con lo que teníamos pero esto
nos ayuda a que la fórmula se vuelva más
fácil por qué porque ahora si ponemos el
estiramiento del enésimo rebote en el
enésimo rebote la fórmula se hace más
fácil porque nos quedan 0.6 elevado a la
enésima potencia x 120 verdad en el
rebote cero el rebote es cero nos queda
0.6 a la cero que son 1 % 20 en el
primer rebote 0.6 a la 1 está un 10.6
es 0.6 por el estiramiento anterior y
entonces esto ya está en términos de
rebotes que ya nos va a ayudar más a
resolver la pregunta entonces ahora sí
qué pasa con el estiramiento cuando la
cuerda del rebote número 2 ya podemos
utilizar nuestra fórmula más
directamente y ahora sí voy a sacar la
calculadora saber nuestra fórmula nos
dice 120 120 x 0.6 elevado elevado a la
potencia 12 elevado a la 12
esto de aquí va a tener el orden de las
operaciones bien porque los exponentes
van antes que las multiplicaciones
entonces 0.6 a la 12 a ver nos da 0.26
pies entonces lo vamos a poner por aquí
son 0.26 y eso lo que nos dice es que se
estira bien poquitos estira muy muy
poquito la cuerda se estira más o menos
como 3 pulgadas que es súper poquito
espero que te haya sido útil este
ejemplo disculpa por el replanteamiento
que tuve que hacer y eso de cambiar pues
de cambiar brincos por rebotes pero vaya
pienso que fue instructivo para explicar
que es bueno que nuestra fórmula siempre
cuadre con pues con la n de la cual
estamos hablando por ejemplo aquí
teníamos brincos uno pero era 10
entonces ahí estaba un poquito desfasado
pero ya que pongo todo en términos de
los rebotes aquí estaba el rebote 0 y
era 0.6 a la 0 aquí en el rebote uno
llega a 0.6 a la 1 aquí igual el rebote
20 puntos 6 al cuadrado y así la fórmula
cuadra va mucho mejor espero que te haya
gustado